wie gehen wie geht's jetzt weiter mit
europa reden wir drüber mit einem mann
der sich da super auskennt weil er
tatsächlich in europa wird mit oder
schubert
oder würdest du sagen zusammenfassen
woran ist geert wilders in den
niederlanden gescheitert ich würde sagen
an den holländern also ich glaube die
anderen wirklich recht liegen lassen und
die rechten wird sie können eigene auch
wirklich ein bisschen leidtun
ich meine so als echter nadal ist ihr
stolz sein auf dein land auf seine
nation möchte dann wird in holland
geboren direkten landwirte sagt er so
ist wie sie mit häusern und natürlich
selber ist natürlich auch schon so ein
bisschen verstörenden charakter hatte
ein mann partei als einzige mitglied der
ist fordert über edeka rewe und möglich
also wirklich sehr
der banker ist viele also distanzierter
das schreckt auch ein thema ab jetzt
habe er dann will ich die nächste
zitterpartie in frankreich ist es für
dich vorstellbar dass die eurozone doch
noch auseinanderbricht und was würde das
für deutschland bedeuten ich werde jetzt
nicht gleich ob man es gibt ja auch noch
länder die in die eu ein ball liegt der
beitrittsverhandlungen zum beispiel mit
der türkei
jetzt aber sieht gar nicht so schlecht
ich würde es nicht immer gleich ein
auseinanderbrechen reden also seine eu
das ist ja auch eine beziehung wegen
seiner ehe und ich glaube jede beziehung
da braucht man gemeinsam mit viele
gemeinsame hoffnung man seine wünsche
und gemeinsame träume und in meiner
beziehung an meiner ehe war so meine
frau und ich wir hatten beide einen
gemeinsamen großen wunsch wir wünschen
und beide eigentlichen anderen partner
das schweißt zusammen und ich glaube das
hat auch seinen frankreich die die
bleiben zusammen einfach so aus bot also
weil man dem anderen kein neues glück
könnt also die gern gemeinsam alt um dem
anderen beim verhalten
jetzt gibt ja immer wieder verschiedene
konfliktfelder in der eu die eu staaten
osteuropa zb die fühlen sich oft
benachteiligt da gab es vor ein paar
tagen den sogenannten es wirklich so
nutella gipfel der vorwurf der
osteuropäerin kern der oft nicht nur
minderwertige lebensmittel ist sprachlos
auch essen wie gott in frankreich und
mich essen wie gott in rumänien ich hab
das mal
ich glaube die lebensmittel sind gar
nicht so unterschiedlich also bei dem
rumänischen mutter ist halt ohne nüsse
und schokolade
ansonsten total identisch also mit den
unterschied erkennt sie wirklich nur an
geschmack
und ich glaube nicht dass die lebens
wieder direkt schlechter sind die sind
halt einfach nur überlagert und gelaufen
naja so ja je nachdem woher kommt und
das ist natürlich aber wirklich
gefährlich das muss man dann also auch
schon eine ländliche putin ware im
urlaub und das irgendwie es lag einfach
verlieren müssen sie dann schon wirklich
aufregend für deutsche nicht zum verzehr
geeignet für eine lösung willst du dich
abschließend selber als europäer in fünf
seiner art europäischen patriotismus
patriotismus aber ich bin ich bin ja
europa
also ich meine ich hatte einerseits so
von meinem vater das südländische
schüttelt hier einfach am hang nur die
glut
[Musik]
auf der andern seite von meiner mutter
aber dann eher das modische
lohnentwicklung hatte körperlich bin ich
bin ja so frank das ganze wird gesteuert
von einem sächsischen gehirn dass ich
nicht mehr richtig deutschland also da
geht zur mannschaft nicht so leicht tut
es ist nicht einfach so passiert
[Applaus]